clic clic waouh tu fais hyper bien le
clic
merci abattoirs pour se protéger des
prédateurs le champignon à nu est
capable d'expulser sa fumerolles putride
avec une puissance produits
[Musique]
priorité au direct nous interrompons
votre programme le premier ministre
edouard philippe est sur le point de
faire une allocution concernant le
confinement selon nos sources proches de
matignon on peut s'attendre à des
déclarations fortes et à des annonces
particulièrement impactante pour la
suite des événements on les coupe tout
de suite et quinze premiers jours
d'avril seront difficiles je vous
rappelle que nous sommes ensemble pour
cette édition spéciale coronavirus
jusqu'à demain matin on se retrouve tout
de suite pour décrypter ces annonces
particulièrement forte avec notre panel
d'experts spécialistes en annonce
particulièrement forte
[Applaudissements]
bon ben voilà on est toujours là ça fait
maintenant plus de deux semaines qu'on
est confiné et je veux pas spoiler mais
c'est pas terminé
moi je suis toujours en télétravail
comme vous pouvez le constater que je
vous propose aujourd'hui comme je vous
l'avais promis à deux semaines c'est de
répondre à un certain nombre de
questions comme par exemple celle que
vous avez le plus posé ou celles qui
m'ont semblé le plus pertinentes et des
fois c'était les mêmes
allez c'est parti je fais quoi si j'ai
l'impression d'être malade alors déjà il
ya un site qui a été mis en ligne sur
lequel vous pouvez aller si vous avez
l'impression d'être malade et qui vous
donne la conduite à tenir
je vous mets le lien dans la description
mais de base ce que vous pouvez vous
dire d'emblée c'est que ça va se passer
au téléphone que vous ayez besoin d'un
renseignement avec le numéro vert a été
mis en place
que vous ayez besoin d'une télé
consultation avec votre médecin ou que
vous ayez besoin d'après le 15 ans parce
que ça va pas ou parce que vous n'êtes
pas sûr que il faut que vous alliez aux
urgences
de toute façon ne vous déplacez pas
téléphoner donc sortait pas comme ça
épuise y parle un petit truc à part mais
qu importe encore m
prenez pas n'importe quel médicament qui
traînent géré ou dans la boîte à
pharmacie
on sait par exemple que les anti
inflammatoires ça a tendance à aggraver
les choses donc si vous êtes malade
appelez votre médecin ou le numéro vert
dans un premier temps ou appeler le 15
si vous avez des signes de souffrance
respiratoires alors vous attendez pas à
ce qu'on nous fasse un test de dépistage
sauf dans des cas très précis genre si
vous êtes une personne particulièrement
vulnérable ou si on a l'impression que
vous développez une forme grave où
poussent des personnels de santé et
cetera mais sinon la façon dont ça se
passait juste au téléphone le médecin va
recueillir les informations en fonction
des signes que vous le décrivez
il va dire ok ça ressemble quand même
beaucoup aux colis de 19 donc dans le
doute
restez chez vous quarantaine strict
c'est à dire vous ne sortez même pas
faire les courses vous aurez 4-1 les
faire à votre place
alors petit truc il ya d'autres virus
qui tourne en ce moment qui peuvent
donner des signes qui ressemble un petit
peu donc si ça se trouve vous allez être
en quarantaine chez vous mais vous
n'avez pas vraiment le coronavirus ça
peut être un autre virus
bon c'est pas très important parce que
ça change rien de toute façon il n'y a
pas de traitement donc c'est juste
précaution restez chez vous ce que ça
change par contre c'est pour la suite
faut pas vous imaginer
parce que vous avez été en quarantaine
pour suspicion de kobe 19 ça veut dire
forcément que vous êtes immunisés voilà
on en parlera plus tard mais c'est
important
est ce que c'est vrai qu'on perd le goût
et l'odorat bas au départ les mêmes
jusqu'à ya pas si longtemps que ça on
considère elle que ce n'était pas un
signe spécifique de covile 19 mais quand
même il ya eu pas mal de gens qui ont
signalé qu'ils avaient c'est qu'ils
allaient ces signaux là donc il ya eu
des études qui ont été faites notamment
à l'initiative des orl français
d'ailleurs et on pense de plus en plus
que une perte brutale de doha est debout
1 et 2 vont ensemble qui n'est pas lié à
un mais complètement bouchée des voies
respiratoires complètement triste parce
que sinon perdre le goût l'odorat et le
goût c'est normal brutal le goût et
l'odorat avec n'est pas complètement
bouché magenta
oui c'est plutôt un signe en faveur de
covin 19 pour préciser les choses il ya
une étude européenne qui est en cours à
ce qu'on sait pour l'instant c'est que
chez les patients qui ont guéri dans
l'aliment ce majorité des cas ça revient
ça peut mettre un petit peu de temps
mais ça revient est-ce que les chiens et
les chats peuvent transmettre le virus
alors la réponse à cette question là
elle est un tout petit peu plus complexe
que oui ou non
pour l'instant ce qu'on sait c'est que
dans l'état actuel des choses le virus
on peut pas le transmettre aux chiens et
aux chats donc ils ne peuvent pas être
malades du virus par contre ce qu'on
sait c'est que le virus il peut survivre
un certain nombre de temps sur un
certain nombre de matières je vais vous
remettre un lien dans la description
pour que vous fassiez une idée du coût
bas un chien un chat qui se fait tousser
dessus par exemple eh bah il peut avoir
du virus sur lui et si après vous le
papouiller que vous mettez la main sur
votre visage de sa vous pouvez chopé le
virus par l'intermédiaire du chien ou du
chat
a priori c'est des choses qui sont rares
puisque la transmission dans l'immense
majorité des cas cette transmission
directe mais quand même bien risque du
coup qu'est ce qu'on fait là on adopte
les chiens les chats les mêmes gestes
barrières carré tout un chacun c'est à
dire que rouleur tout ce pas dessus on
leur éternue pas dessus on fait ça dans
son cloud com comme d'habitude on leur
sert pas la pâte pour leur dire bonjour
non les papouilles pas en se tripotant
le visage après et puis on les embrasse
pas non plus surtout avec la langue
de toute façon c'est dégueulasse je vous
rappelle que leur langue c'est quand
même leurs gants de toilette dit qu'il a
des trucs avec ça je vous avais pas
envie d'entrer dans la bouche
donc j'ai de l'ariège classiques
habituels avec les animaux pourquoi on
fait pas des tests à tout le monde alors
c'est vrai que l' oms encourage vivement
tous les pays à faire des dépistages
massive dans les pays où ça se fait on
voit que ça fonctionne plutôt bien alors
pourquoi est ce que nous nommons réserve
ça aux cas graves aux personnes
vulnérables aux personnels de santé etc
pourquoi est ce qu'on ne fait pas ça à
tout le monde bah c'est bête comme tout
c'est juste qu'on n'a pas assez de tests
pour dépister tout le monde voilà ça va
changer bientôt mais ça on va on va
reparler après est ce que les tests sont
fiables
alors c'est vrai qu'il ya la question de
la fiabilité des tests qui se pose parce
qu'il ya plusieurs cas dans lesquels des
personnes ont été testées négatives et
finalement il s'avère lequel elle
s'était infectée
pour le moment ce qu'on sait c'est que
si on est testé positif
c'est fiable quasi à 100% par contre si
on est testé négatif là c'est moins sûr
on parle de 60% de fiabilité et puis il
ya plusieurs hypothèses sur les raisons
pour lesquelles ces variables dans les
cas négatifs
il y en a qui pensent que certains
patients infectés n'excluait pas de
virus donc on n'en retrouve pas au
niveau des prélèvements pas l'hypothèse
la plus vraisemblable mais en tout cas
les avancées il y en a d'autres de façon
plus pragmatique qui disent que le
prélèvement dans les cas des faux
négatifs des prélèvements qui sont pas
fait assez profondément
voilà du coup on va pas chercher le
virus là où il se passe parce que c'est
pas dans les narines que ça se passait
vraiment plus profond sous vraiment y
aller si on veut trouver du liant dans
tous les cas évidemment il faut
améliorer tout ça les gens qui
travaillent que ce soit au niveau de la
technique de prélèvement des raies
quiches et cetera en attendant il ya une
option qui est si vous êtes testés
négatifs ont refait plusieurs fois le
collège blanc pour être sûr voilà
pourquoi on n'utilise pas la chloroquine
alors pour être très factuelle la
chloroquine c'est une molécule qui est
utilisé pour fabriquer des médicaments
contre le paludisme mais aussi certaines
zones lundi comme le lupus par exemple
le fait qu'elle ait possiblement une
action sur les coronavirus c'est quelque
chose qui est pas nouveau qu'on connaît
mais qui n'a jamais été prouvée chez
l'homme et là on a plusieurs pays est en
tout cas en france notamment un médecin
qui est persuadé que c'est bon ça
fonctionne il faut y aller faut en
donner à tout le monde sauf que c'est
pas comme ça que ça se passe
pour pouvoir utiliser un médicament pour
une autre raison que celle pour laquelle
il a été autorisé au départ il faut
faire des tests faut faire des études
dans le cas de crise comme en ce moment
il ya des procédures accélérées à des
procédures simplifiées d'autorisations
temporaires d'utilisation
mais quand même on fait à n'importe quoi
il faut faire des prêts test pour savoir
1,6 et efficace et 2,6 et pas dangereux
pour que ses études elle soit fiable il
faut qu'elles respectent un certain
nombre de règles de critères il faut
qu'il respecte une certaine méthodologie
et là soyons clairs l'étude dont on
parle celle du professeur là où elle
n'est pas fiable dans la mesure où elle
ne respecte pas complètement toutes ces
règles là ça veut pas dire que ça marche
pas parce qu'il ya d'autres gens qui se
sont penchés sur la question si ça veut
dire que là pour l'instant avec ça on
peut pas juger qu'il faut attendre les
résultats d'autres études sur un plus
grand nombre de patients avec une
méthodologie un petit peu plus carré que
ça pour être sûr donc pour l'instant on
ne sait pas si c'est efficace pour ce
qui est d'être dangereux on a déjà les
premiers cas de gens qui ont essayé ne
se soigner tout seul à la chloroquine et
qui ont été hospitalisées pour des
problèmes cardiaques
a priori on avait
déjà les premiers cas de décès ou
courrier on ne fait pas n'importe quoi
on attend les résultats des études et
surtout on se prend pas des médicaments
tout seul comme ça on attend que le
médecin ait le droit de les prescrire
est-ce que je dois désinfecter mes
courses alors attention là encore une
fois on ne sait pas tout on apprend les
choses au fur à mesure
donc il faut rester humble et prudent
évidemment pour l'instant ce qu'on sait
c'est que le virus il peut survivre
plusieurs heures voire plusieurs jours
sur différents types de surface par
contre ça veut pas dire qu'il est
forcément contaminants à chaque fois ça
veut dire qu'il ya du virus sur la
surface
cela veut pas dire qu'il y en a assez
pour nous infectés donc c'est déjà c'est
pas la même chose pour l'instant on
pense que passer trois heures à
l'extérieur du corps humain qui peut en
rester sur les surfaces par contre il
est plus contaminant donc il n'est pas à
risque pas de nous affecter
deuxième chose tout désinfecter ça ne
sert à rien par contre ce qu'il faut
faire quand vous rentrez de faire vos
courses
première chose vous laver les mains
après il ya des précautions
éventuellement à prendre avec les
emballages
alors ce que vous pouvez faire c'est
soit vous les enlevez voulait jeter et
vous stockez parce que vous allez
acheter vos aliments et c'est comme ça
dans du bois tu sois si vous pouvez pas
les retirer pour une raison x ou y
genre d'humour tout ça vous enlevez le
suremballage et de l'emballage qui reste
vous passez un coup de chiffon à coups
de sopalin c'est mieux comme ça c'est à
usage unique un coup de sopalin humide
avec de l'eau tiède dessus le vinaigre
blanc ça marche pas sur les virus ça
sert à rien et désinfecter ça sert à
rien non plus voilà un coup
mécaniquement vous frotter un peu ça
enlève éventuellement les dernières
traces de virus était vous pouvez ranger
comme ça et une fois que vous avez fini
évidemment vous vous re laver les mains
comme ça que vous êtes tranquille et
pendant tout ce temps là vous touchez
pas à votre visage comme comme
d'habitude
du coup on entend dire aussi qu'il
faudrait laisser ses courses reposer
trois heures comme ça après on est sûr
qu'elles sont plus contaminantes avant
de les ranger
vous pouvez faire ça si vous avez envie
par contre se fait pas ça avec les
produits frais ou les surgelés par
exemple si vous n'avez sûrement pas
envie d'avoir une gastro en ce moment
non je mens pas
vous avez sûrement rarement envie
d'avoir une gastro mais en ce moment
encore mois et votre médecin a sûrement
autre chose à [ __ ] que de s'occuper de
votre geiser non sinon vous le reste
pour vos aliments bat déjà sachez que la
cuisson ça tue le virus donc tout ce qui
est qu il n'y a pas de souci et pour vos
fruits et aux légumes crus bah vous les
lavez juste à l'eau claire ça suffit
éventuellement vous voulez pelé et voilà
mais le plus important quand vous
manipuler vos courses juste après les
avoir achetées ces les gestes barrière
c'est tout gros vous vous laver les
mains avant et après et vous touchez pas
le visage pendant et ça n'aura pas de
problème quand est-ce qu'on peut sortir
quand on a été malade et oui parce que
la question va commencer à se poser de
plus en plus vu qu'il ya de plus en plus
de gens qui ont été confinés par placés
en quarantaine même chez eux avec des
signes évocateurs du coc vide 19 et que
13 heureusement l'immense majorité en
aguerris mais du coup après qu'est ce
qu'on fait alors pour connaître des gens
qui ont été dans cette situation je peux
vous dire que la réponse de à partir de
quand on a le droit de ressortir de chez
soi elle n'est pas si facile que ça à
voir c'est même très très compliqué du
coup j'ai poser directement la question
au ministère de la santé et pour être
très clair
voilà la réponse qu'ils m'ont donnée
déjà là on parle de personnes qui ne
sont pas des personnes à risque qui sont
pas des personnes vulnérables qui n'ont
pas eu une forme grave puisque elles
sont restées chez elles et ses bas de ce
qu'on appelle la population générale
donc si vous êtes dans ce cas là si vous
êtes quelqu'un de langue là on va dire
que vous avez eu des signes qui sont
évocateurs du coc u19 que votre médecin
vous a dit restez chez vous en
quarantaine ne sortait pas et que ça y
est vous êtes guéri
à partir de quand vous pouvez sortir
d'alors il faut que votre médecin au
téléphone et valider le fait que oui
effectivement vous avez tous les signes
de guérison ça c'est la première étape
ensuite il ya un délai à respecter il
faut que le début de vos signes ils
datent d'il ya plus de huit jours après
il faut évidemment que vous n'ayez plus
de fièvre c'est à dire que vous prenez
votre température deux fois par jour
alors sans avoir pris de médicaments qui
la font baisser genre du paracétamol ou
alors il n'y a plus de 12 a en tout cas
vous prenez votre température deux fois
par jour il faut qu'à chaque fois elle
soit inférieur à 37 8 ça c'est un autre
critère et puis si vous avez eu une gêne
respiratoire
il faut qu'elle ait disparu depuis au
moins 48 heures donc si vous avez toutes
ces conditions qui sont réunis vous
pouvez passer de quarantaine à
confinement c'est à dire que vous mettez
à respecter les mêmes règles que tous
les autres vous pouvez sortir chez vous
mais mêmes critères que tout le monde et
puis surtout mêmes gestes barrières que
tout le monde
par contre pas besoin de porter un
masque je rappelle que les masques c'est
essentiellement pour les malades et le
personnel soignant il y en a pas assez
donc où leur laisse on utilise pas pour
nous alors il y en a peut-être qui sont
tentés de porter un masque parce qu'ils
ont entendu dire que même une fois qu'on
est guéri on reste contagieux pendant
plusieurs jours voire plusieurs semaines
alors c'est vrai qu'il ya eu des études
chinoises au début qui ont montré que
plusieurs semaines après le début des
premiers signes on peut continuer à
excréter du virus mais c'est un petit
peu la même chose qu'avec
le temps de contact sur les surfaces
c'est a priori tu pas suffisamment pour
être contaminants c'est à dire on peut
il crée t du virus mais pas assez pour
infecter quelqu'un d'autre en tout cas
pas si on respecte les gestes barrière
classique
je vous remets tout ça aussi dans les
dans la description vous pouvez aussi
retourner voir les vidéos précédentes
que j'ai fait à ce sujet là mais en tout
cas gestes barrières pour tout le monde
mais pas de là ce qui est est ce que ça
va durer encore longtemps
alors désolé mais même réponse que dans
la vidéo précédente
on sait pas là ce qu'on sait c'est que
le confinement a été prolongée jusqu'au
15 avril
et pour le reste on a des petits indices
qui nous permettent de nous imaginer des
choses mais rien de plus
alors parmi ces indices ce qu'on sait
c'est que le conseil scientifique sur
lequel le gouvernement s'appuie pour
prendre ses décisions
d'emblée et il l'a répété ya pas
longtemps il a estimé qu'il faudrait au
minimum six semaines de confinement donc
en tout six semaines de confinement le
cube début ça nous amène à fin avril
début mai parallèlement on a le ministre
de l'éducation nationale qui a annoncé
qu'ils pensaient ouvrir les écoles les
collèges et lycées etc
le 4 mai évidemment c'est pour l'instant
il est pas un médium il sait pas comment
ça va évoluer etc
mais ça nous donne quand même
l'impression que l'on table sur des bus
mais altère pas avant que quoi qu'il
arrive il ya aussi un certain nombre de
scientifiques qui disent que ça risque
d'être un petit peu limité qui fera
peut-être prolongé on n'en sait rien on
va pas s'imaginer les choses pour
l'instant je pense que raisonnablement
on peut se dire fin avril-début mai au
mieux et pour le reste on attend de voir
comment l'épidémie évolue comment le
nombre de cas évolué
si le système hospitalier arrive a tant
bien que mal géré tous les cas on attend
et voilà comment ça va se passer la fin
du confinement
là encore ça va dépendre de l'évolution
de l'épidémie donc on peut pas vraiment
savoir aujourd'hui et puis surtout j'ai
pas envie de faire de la crise sanitaire
fiction mais un scénario qui est
possible c'est avant la levée du
confinement ont fait des dépistage
massif et jeudi des dépistage massif
parce qu'en ce moment il ya deux types
de tests qui sont en train d'être
produit à très très grande échelle pour
la france 1 qui permet de savoir si on
est infecté c'est la solution qu'on
utilise déjà mais aussi un autre qui
permet de savoir si on a été en contact
avec le virus
et si on est immunisé donc on peut
imaginer qu'on va faire c'est est au
plus grand nombre de personnes possible
et que les infectés ils vont rester en
quarantaine les immunisés ils vont
pouvoir sortir en continuant à respecter
les gestes barrière évidemment et les
gens qui ont été ni malade ni immunisés
bal aura peut-être une sorte de sortie
de confinement progressif que de toute
façon ce qui est sûr et certain c'est
que ça va pas s'arrêter comme ça du jour
au lendemain et qu'on va pas retrouver
notre ville allant directement ça c'est
évident attention évidemment tout ça
c'est juste des suppositions
donc il n'ya rien d'officiel on peut
nous faire que imaginez le truc voile
alors avant de vous laisser tranquille
ou pas tranquille peut se trouvait pas
tous tranquilles je voulais juste
revenir sur deux ou trois trucs un petit
peu plus généraux au niveau de
l'épidémie et du confinement
alors déjà c'est vrai qu'on vit une
période difficile tout cas pour un grand
nombre de personnes on va partir sur un
euphémisme dans ce genre de situation
c'est assez humain de chercher quelqu'un
contre qui dirait
sa colère c'est humain sauf que ça sert
à rien ça nous fait pas du bien
en vrai et surtout c'est contre
productif
donc déjà oui il ya eu des erreurs de
commises les gens qui gère cette crise
il ya des moments où ils ont merdé
bon déjà je n'ai pas une bonne façon de
gérer ce genre de crise il ya la façon
qui est la plus adaptée pour au pays
dans lequel on se trouve avec ses
ressources ses particularités
donc il sera temps une fois que tout
sera terminé que les gens qui savent de
quoi ils parlent
c'est important de laisser parler les
gens qui savent de quoi ils parlent que
ces gens-là fasse le point et qu'il nous
explique comment mieux faire la
prochaine fois
notamment comment mieux faire pour
anticiper parce que la plupart des
problèmes qu'il a eus c'est à ce niveau
là mais je ne laisserai personne dire
qu'il ya eu du retard sur la prise de
décision s'agissant du confinement web
on pourra dire qu'on en parle pas
maintenant
un autre truc dans des situations comme
celle qu'on est en train de vivre en ce
moment un truc est encore plus important
que d'habitude et c'est déjà super
important c'est l'unité du coup ça sert
à rien d'aller épié son voisin pour voir
s'il fait bien les choses comme il faut
ça sert à rien d'afficher les gens qui
font un jogging bien dehors ça sert à
rien de gaulle et contre les gens qui
vont se promener avec leur gamin et
c'est déjà dans la grande majorité des
cas si vous vous êtes dehors pour les
voir ces gens là c'est parce que vous
estimez que vous avez une bonne raison
d'être dehors sauf qu'eux aussi ils
estiment avoir une bonne raison d'être
dehors allons pas à mettre son nez dans
les affaires des autres sans trop nous
sur nous et sur ce qu'on peut faire
parce que en plus de servir à rien
s'énerver comme ça contre les autres ça
la fâcheuse tendance à plus ou moins
inconsciemment valider les petites
entorses qu'on a un petit peu envie de
faire nous mêmes
c'est le genre oui bah lui là il promène
son chien à trois fois par jour donc moi
je veux bien me faire un petit plaisir
et c'est non voilà donc ce qui est bien
c'est l'être un peu empathique un peu
bienveillant
surtout de veiller hyper attentivement
au respect des consignes par la seule
personne qu'on maîtrise plus ou mois
c'est à dire d'où m sur wii
ensuite un autre truc à garder à
l'esprit on ne combat pas une épidémie
en cherchant à se protéger soi même on
combat une épidémie collectivement en
adoptant des comportements qui font que
le virus circule le moins possible déjà
pour l'empêcher d'atteindre les
personnes les plus vulnérables
ensuite pour éviter que le système de
santé soient débordés et à la fin pour
faire en sorte que le nombre de cas
diminue
suffisamment pour que l'épidémie
s'éteignent c'est comme ça que ça marche
donc on la joue collectif et on respecte
les consignes on va pas chercher plus
loin
et donc là à ce moment précis vous vous
dites que c'est de l'art l'image a
changé oui ma caméra m'a lâchée en plein
milieu du tournage
donc je me fie n'y avait qu'une autre
caméra voilà c'était pour un petit
interlude de technique on reprend oui
donc je disais puisqu'on est dans le
collectif puisqu'on est dans l'empathie
et être si vraiment on a envie de se
mêler des affaires des autres
on peut penser aux personnes qui sont en
difficulté parce qu'il y en a en ce
moment ça peut être quelqu'un qui vit
mal le confinement qui dit mal
l'épidémie soit parce que elle gère pas
la solitude soit parce que la malade il
angoisse peut y avoir plein de raisons à
ça donc dans ces cas là bas c'est pas
mal de prendre des nouvelles c'est pas
mal de se faire des petites discussions
c'est pas mal de dents voyez des
messages d'encouragement ça fait ça fait
du bien en vrai il ya aussi les cas de
figure très différent de personnes qui
sont en danger chez elle et pour ça je
vous remets dans la description toutes
les infos pour avoir la conduite à tenir
en cas de violence conjugale ou de
violences sur enfants par exemple
bon voilà c'est toi ça va être terminé
pour de bon juste avant de partir
évidemment une immense pensée un grand
grand un immense merci à tous les gens
qui continuent à travailler en ce moment
pour nous sortir de là où juste pour
qu'on puisse continuer à vivre
par exemple les personnes qui
travaillent dans des magasins
d'alimentation ou dans les
afin qu'ils sont toujours ouverts comme
les pharmacies etc le personnel de
nettoyage et d'hygiène de ménage de
ramassage des déchets terrasse est hyper
important surtout surtout en ce moment
il ya plein d'autres catégories socio
professionnelles comme ça qui sont
toujours au boulot pour nous donc merci
à tous et puis évidemment
évidemment le personnel de santé qu'ils
soient partout immense bravo immense
merci à vous remerciera jamais assez
c'est hyper bien que tout le monde
applaudit sauf naître à 20 heures tous
les soirs mais ce que j'espère surtout
c'est que à la fin de tout ça on prenne
vraiment conscience de qui est
indispensable et que ça change la donne
pour la suite voilà dtc c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve bientôt pour
de nouvelles vidéos évidemment d'ici là
plus que jamais prenez soin de vous et
prenez soin des autres
restez chez vous mettez vous bien quand
même et surtout portez vous bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]